you're only two years older than me
darling where have you been on my life I
have a confession to make
when I first emerged from my mother's
womb I was already rehearsing my Academy
Thank You speech I thought it was so
long ago mercifully for you I've
forgotten it but I haven't forgotten who
to thank the Academy of course for this
extraordinary honor and my fellow
nominees
Kenneth Nik Jonah
dear max I'm so proud to be in your
company and
of course I wouldn't be here at all if
it went from Michael Mills and is
enchanting film beginner and my screen
partner of of course you and McGregor
that's superb artists who I would
happily share this award with if I had
any decency but I don't how all
producers of Olympus films especially
Leslie were dying and Miranda de pulsky
all the people had focused for their
tremendous generosity and support and
not to mention my little band of Jean
provocateur will loop it and his wife
Berta
Carter Cohn Pippa Markham Perry Zimmer
who've tried so hard to keep me out of
jail my daughter Amanda who always makes
me proud and lastly my long-suffering
wife Elaine